عدنان ما هي ابرز النقاط
التي استطعت ان تلاحظها في هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي
اليوم نعم جمال يبدو ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن سيعود في جولته
الخامسه هذه للمنطقه في غضون اربعه اشهر
نحن نتحدث على عن تمام نحو اربعه اشهر على
بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه على على قطاع غزه
سيعود ايه بشيء يحمله بشكل رسمي ومعلن من
من الدوحه حيث اشار رئيس الوزراء القطري
وزير الخارجيه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
الثاني بانه تم تسلم رد حركه حماس على
الاتفاق الاطاري او اطار الاتفاق مقترح
الهدنه الذي جاء بعد اجتماع باريس خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه وقال ان هذا الرد بمجمله
ايجابي لكن هناك تضمن ملاحظات بطبيعه
الحال هل سيتم نقلها الى الجانب
الاسرائيلي واشار ايضا في معرض رده على
بعض الاسئله ان تاخر الرد على هذا المقترح
من قبل حركه حماس جاء نتيجه الظروف التي
تفرضها الاوضاع بشكل اساسي على الارض
وبالتالي قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بانه
سيحمل هذا المقترح الى او الملاحظات الى
الجانب الاسرائيلي وبالتالي سيستمع اليهم
بشكل اساسي كان هناك تر تركيز كبير جمال
عن الحديث عن مقترح الهدنه الذي تم او يتم
تداوله بعد ان تم انتظار حركه حماس لايام
لتقدم ردها الان اصبح هذا الرد
حاضرا قطر قالت بان اي تصعيد عمليا في
المنطقه واتساع دائره التصعيد كل ذلك يصعب
عمليه المفاوضات ويصعب الوصول الى حل
وايقاف ل اطلاق النار وايقاف للحرب بشكل
عام في قطاع غزه اتساع نطاق التصعيد جمال
كان ايضا حاضرا بشكل او باخر عندما تم تمت
الاشاره الى الاحداث التي شهدتها الايام
والاسبوعين تحديدا الماضيين هنا في
المنطقه في اشاره الى مقتل الجنود
الامريكيين الثلاثه في في الاردن وا وايضا
الردود التي نفذتها الضربات التي نفذتها
واشنطن في سوريا والعراق وا ايضا في اليمن
كان هناك ادانه بطبيعه الحال ادانه قطريه
ل ما حدث للجنود الامريكيين الثلاثه
والهجوم لكن ايضا كان هناك تحذير من اتساع
دائره التصعيد في المنطقه وقال رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الرحمن الثاني ان الدوحه حذرت منذ
البدايه من ان كل هذا الامر واتساع دائره
التصعيد لن تساعد في انهاء الحرب مطالبه
جميع الاطراف بضبط النس بشكل او باخر وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي جمال كان هناك ايضا
تحدث عن نقطه مهمه عندما اشار الى ان هناك
مسعا جدي في هذه الجوله الخامسه له في
المنطقه ل لبناء مسار مستدام للسلام في
المنطقه يفضي الى اقامه اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه باطار زمني واضح بالاضافه الى
بنود اخرى و واشار الى اطراف تحاول تعطيل
هذا المسار الذي تسعى اليه واشنطن بحدي
قوله وقال ان هذا ما بحثه
ايه منذ بدايه زيارته في الرياض ثم في مصر
ثم هنا في الدوحه وهو ما سيحمله ايضا
بمجمله
الى تلبيب غدا وبعد ذلك طبعا في الضفه
الغربيه اذا نحن نتحدث عن بندين اساسيين
تم الحديث عنهما بشكل اساسي نتحدث عن
مقترح الهدنه المؤقته وتسلم رد حركه حماس
اخيرا على هذا المقترح وبالتالي وهو ما
سيحمل الى الجانب الاسرائيلي لتعليق على
هذه الملاحظات بطبيعه الحال
وثم نتقدم اكثر في هذا الاتفاق او ربما
يكون هناك تحفظات اسرائيليه لا نعلم البند
الثاني هو موضوع اتساع التصعيد في المنطقه
تم الحديث كما قلنا جمال عن ان السعي بشكل
اساسي عن محاوله راب هذا الاتساع ومنع
اتساع التصعيد في صار مطالبه واضحه بعدم
استغلال امريكيا بطبيعه الحال بعدم
استغلال الحرب في غزه لتنفيذ عمليات خارج
ايه او في نطاق الاقليم بشكل عام وايضا
مطالبه قطريه بضبط النفس في من جميع
الاطراف في هذا الاطار